[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام واحييكم وهذه التاسعه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
استعدادها تسليم المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
لجيش النظام السوري
زوال
السلام
والمعارضه تشكك
روسيا ترد على شروط اوكرانيا للتفاوض بقصف
بعشرات الصواريخ على العاصمه والبيت
في مصر مشروع قانون الاحوال الشخصيه يثير
للجدل قبل تقديمه الى البرلمان
[موسيقى]
اكد وزير الخارجيه التركيه مولود شاوش
اوغلو ان انقره مستعده لنقل السيطره
بمناطق وجودها في سوريا الى دمشق مولود
شاوش اوبلو قال ان تركيا ترغب بعوده
اللاجئين السوريين وانقره تعمل على تامين
ذلك اشار الى انه يلتقي نظيره السوري فيصل
المقداد قريبا لضمان عوده امنه للاجئين
قبلوا دعى الى تطبيق القرار الاممي 22 54
بشان الحال في سوريا
[موسيقى]
وفي اول تعليق كردي سوري على تطورات بين
انقره والنظام الاسد برعايه روسيه اعتبرت
الاداره الذاتيه الكرديه في شمال شرق
سوريا ان اللقاء يهدف لترسيخ اقدام الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وحزبه في السلطه
قبل الانتخابات التركيه القادمه وان هذه
اللقاءات ستطور لمرحله جديده من الصفقات
والخطط المعاديه لمصالح السوريين والسعي
لاحياء اتفاقيه اضنه التي كانت مشرفه
وجائره بحق شعوب المنطقه كما طلبت الاداره
كلا من روسيا والنظام السوري بالكشف عن
فحو هذه اللقاءات الامنيه
والعسكريه بعد 12 عاما من العداء
والاحتلال والتدمير في سوريا التي تعيش
اوضاعا ماساويه بحسب التصريحات
المزيد ينضم الينا من اسطنبول زيدان زينجو
مراسل العربيه اهلا بك زيدان قبل ان نبدا
في فحوى ما يمكن ان يكون قد حصل في هذه
الاجتماعات وما سرب حتى هذه اللحظه دعمنا
نتحدث عن تصريحات التركيه التي تقول بانها
مستعده لتسليم المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
للنظام بحال عوده الاستقرار السياسي مفهوم
هذا الاستقرار السياسي تركيا ما هو
نعم ميسون حتى الان الروايه الرسميه
التركيه تعرف لاستقرار السياسي بانه تطبيق
القرارات الامميه
تطبيق القرارات الاماميه المتعلقه في
الانتقال السياسي في سوريا حتى الان هذا
هذه هي الروايه الرسميه لكن اليوم
التطورات المتسارعه حقيقه من خلال لقاءات
بين مسؤولين اتراك
ومسؤولين النظام السوري تثير قلق الجانب
السوري ونتحدث هنا عن المعارضه السوريه
همم لا نتحدث عن الجانب الرسمي لكن عما
شاهدته منصات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وتعليقات وتغريدات لناشطين وصحفيين وايضا
مواطنين في الداخل السوري همم نتحدثون عن
حاله قلق كبيره تسود اوساط المعارضين
السوريين من هذه التطورات الاساسيه مع ان
الامور يبدو انها تسير بتسارع كبير همم
وزراء الدفاع همم
بطبيعه الاحوال اسباب داخليه بحته في مجمل
هذه الاسباب يعني يكفي ان نتحدث ان
الصحافه التركيه الاسبوع الماضي سربت
رساله نقلتها المعارضه الى نظام الاسد
تطالبه فيها بعدم تطبيع العلاقات مع حزب
العداله او مع تركيا او حزب العداله
والتنميه حتى لا يتمكن اردوغان من كسب
ورقه اضافيه يمكن ان تؤثر على حظوظه او
يمكن ان تعطيه حظوظا اكثر في الانتخابات
القادمه لذلك نفهم من هذا الموضوع اننا
ورقه اللاجئين السوريين اليوم هي ورقه
مهمه على طاوله الانتخابات ويمكن اي طرف
يستطيع ان يكسب او هذه الورقه او يحل هذه
القضيه ولو بصوره اعلاميه حتى يمكن ان
تعطيه حظوظا اكبر تجاه الصناديق الاقتراع
واصوات الناخبين لذلك نشات تسارعا كبيرا
همم من اساس الاتراك لتطبيعه على العلاقات
لا شك ان هناك ضغوط روسيه على دمشق وفقما
اكد اكثر من مسؤول لتسريع طلعت مع انقره
لكن بكل الاحوال حتى هنا في انقره والذين
يتابعون هذا الموضوع يقولون بان مسار
تطبيع العلاقات بشكله الطبيعي او عدد عوده
العلاقات الى طبيعتها يحتاج الى وقت طويل
همم اذا لاحظنا ونشرت وسائل الاعلام تركي
اجتماع الذي جرى يوم امس
كنت اريد اشاره الى الرد الفعل الامريكي
ولكن من المهم ايضا
الاجتماعات
[موسيقى]
نعم بالنظر الى ما نشرته وسائل الاعلام
التركيه اليوم عن فحو اجتماعات يوم امس
كان الحديث بان انقر ودمشق اتفقتا على ان
حزب العمال الكردستاني يمثل تحديدا لك الى
البلدين وكان هناك حديث عن توفير ارضيه
مشتركه لعمليات ربما مستقبليه وبدعم روسي
ضد المسلحين الاكراد في شمال وشرق سوريا
ايضا من ضمن احاديث وسائل الاعلام تركيا
وكانت قناه خبر تركيا من ذكرت هذه
التفاصيل ان مشكله ادلب هي همم المشكله
الاكثر او هو المساء المسار الاكثر تحديا
في المفاوضات او المباحثات ما بين
الجانبين اي ان مستقبل القوات التركيه في
سوريا كان على طاوله الاجتماعات سواء على
اجتماع وزراء الدفاع او حتى اجتماعات
اجهزه الاستخبارات بين البلدين في موسكو
خلال الفتره الماضيه لذلك اليوم مستقبل
القوات التركيه يمثل تحديا حقيقه لمستقبل
علاقات ايضا مما ذكرته وسائل الاعلام
التركي
همم توفير بيئه امنه لعوده اللاجئين وضمان
اعاده كاتهم وااا منازلهم واراضيهم وايضا
ضمان عدم محاكمتهم وضمان المضيء نحو
انتخابات همم انتخابات حره ومستقله باشراف
امم
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
هذا وكان وزير الدفاع التركي خلصي اكورد
قد اكد خلال المحادثات التي جمعته بنظيره
الروسي والسوري على العمل المشترك ضد
الارهاب
مكافحه الارهاب اهداء اهم القضايا التي
تناولناها في الاجتماع اكدنا اننا نحترم
وسلامه اراضي وسيادته جميع جيراننا وخاصه
سوريا والعراق هدفنا الوحيد هو محاربه
الارهاب وليس لدينا اي غرض اخر شددنا على
اهميه تحييد اعضاء المنظمات الارهابيه
عسكريه ضد عناصر داعش طبعا بالتعاون مع
التحالف الدولي بقياده الولايات المتحده
هذه العمليه تاتي بعد ثلاثه ايام من هجوم
سنه داعش واستهدف مراكز امنيه وسجن [__]
عناصر لداعش في مدينه الرقه تسبب بمقتل
بمقاتلنا اكراد في شمال سوريا
وقد نشرت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
بيانا عن العمليات التي نفذتها خلال عام
20 22 لمواجهه تنظيم داعش
وتحطيم قدراته بلغ عدد العمليات التي
نفذتها القوات الامريكيه 313 عمليه في
سوريا والعراق قامت القوات الامريكيه ب
122 في سوريا وثمن عمليات منها مع قوات
شريكه ادت العمليات في سوريا الى مقتل 466
من المنتمين لداعش واسلم 215 اما العراق
فقد شهد ما مجموعه 191 عمليه مشتركه كانت
حصيلاتها مقتل 220 من افراد داعش واسر 159
منهم
[موسيقى]
سنتحرك الدائران حتى لو كلف ذلك تصعيدا مع
امريكا طبعا بهذه الجمله ودعا نتنياهو
منصب رئاسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه قبل حوالي
العامين و بعنوان احباط مساعي ايران
لامتلاك سلاح نووي
بمقدمه اولويات الحكومه يعود نتنياهو الى
ذات المنصب اليوم بعد مصادقه الكنيست على
تشكيلته بعد ان حصل على تاييد ثلاثه وستون
نضمن الميزه العسكريه لاسرائيل في المنطقه
المهمه الاولى التي يصرخ بها الاعضاء هنا
ولكنهم يلغونها كما لو انها ليست مهمه هي
التاكد من ان ايران لن تقضي علينا
بالقنابل النوويه يعني احباط جهود طهران
لتطوير ترسانه نوويه تهددنا وتهديد العالم
باسره
[موسيقى]
وذاته بعد عودته من جديد ايران اولا
وثانيا وثا هذا ما ستركز عليه حكومه
نتنياهو الجديده التي ادت اليمين
الدستوريه اليوم رغم تعرضها لانتقادات
واسعه بعد ان تضغط عليها سمه اقصى
اليمنيات بالحفاظ على تفوق اسرائيل
العسكريا طبعا لمنع ايران من تملك سلاح
نووي يهدد ليس اسرائيل وحدها بل العالم
باسره وفقه حديثه حديث جاء خلال استعرضه
الخطوط العريضه لبرنامج حكومته الجديده
امام الكنيست الاسرائيلي طبعا كان نتنياهو
قد اعلن تعيينه افا جالانت احد مساعده
بحزب النقود وزيرا للجيش ويعاد جالنت الذي
كان قائدا سابقا للجبهه الجنوبيه احد
المؤيدين المخلصين له نتنياهو وقد شغل
ايضا عده مناصب وزاريه في الحكومات
السابقه التي تراسها
[موسيقى]
الكنيست الاسرائيلي بكامل هيئاته بدا صباح
اليوم مراسم تنصيب حكومه نتنياهو الجديده
وادت الحكومه السابعه والثلاثون اليمين
القانونيه وبذلك تبدا الحكومه الجديده
الاكثر جدليه في تاريخ اسرائيل ولايتها
بشكل رسمي
الذي يهدد اسرائيل
خبرات ميسي
بالكاد استطاع نتنياهو القاء خطابه بسبب
المقاطعه من قبل اعضاء المعارضه الجديده
بقياده رئيس الوزراء السابق يا ارنافيد
محاولا عرقله مراسم تنصيب حكومه نتنياهو
دوله اسرائيل
بتهدئه الاوضاع اصبحت الحكومه الجديده
المعالم ترتكز على احزاب اقصى اليمين
وابقى نتنياهو في قبضه اللكود وزاره
الدفاع والخارجيه ووزاره التربيه والتعليم
اما المعارضه الاسرائيليه الجديده فهي
قلقه من ان تاخذ هذه الحكومه اليمنيه دوله
اسرائيل الى مسار ينحرف عن الديمقراطيه
مئات الاسرائيليين تظاهر امام الكنيست في
ظل اجراءات امنيه مشدده احتجاجا على هذه
الحكومه الجديده التي يصفونها
بالديكتاتوريه ومطالبين باسقاتها لان كل
غاصي من القدس العربيه
مشاهدينا ننتقل مباشره لكلمات رامز ممثل
الامم المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه في
افغانستان
بحاجه لهذا الوقت للمشاركه
وان نخرج بحلول امل ان اكون قد اوضحت
موقفا
في ضل لي حقيقه ان الحضر كان
له اثر على عملكم
في اسواق الحالات انتم وفريقكم المحلي هل
كنتم هل انتم مستعدين لاثار ذلك وتبعته
ماذا اعددتم
لمواجهه هذا الوطن ثانيا ان اعرف منك
ان يكون تعامل المجتمع الدولي مع طالبا من
اجل
التراجع عن هذا القرار شكرا لك
الجزء الثاني
كل الشركاء وكل المجتمع الدولي
مشارك بالحوار مع طالبان من اجل هذه
الرساله التي تحدثنا عنها اليوم وهي ان
المراه عضو اساسي في المجتمع ولابد من
تربيه احتياجاتها
اخراج المراه من الحياه العامه ووضع كل
هذه القيود لن يؤدي الى نتائج بناء سواء
للاقتصاد او الحياه الاجتماعيه او اي جانب
اخر لمستقبل الافغانستان كنا واضحين معهم
في ذلك همم مشاركه المراه ضروريه
وهذا واستدامه ذلك مهم
وكذلك استدامه الحوار مهم جدا هذا لابد من
استكمال
اقتراحات المجتمع الدولي للمشاركه بشكل
اكثر فاعليه مع طالبا
نحن نعمل
الحياه الاقتصاديه والوضع الاقتصادي
وبتركيز على
الجوانب المتعلقه بعمل المراه
والعمل في قطاع المنظمات غير الحكوميه هو
اكبر مشغل للمراه في افغانستان ولست واثقا
كان القرارات التي تمت اول حوارات حول حظر
المراه من العمل في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
همم
بسبب اعداد النساء العاملات في هذا القطار
وفي كثير من الحالات هؤلاء النساء هن من
يكسبن قوته اسرهن
فمساء الاقتصاد
ومشاركه الشعب وخاصه المراه والفتاه
والفتاه امر مهم جدا
وبالنسبه لما تفعله الامم المتحده لمواجهه
هذا الوضع
لدينا كثير من الخطط الطارئه الا انك كل
هذه القطط هي لصالح الشعب الافغاني
ما نقوم به وما نخطط به هو لتقديم الدعم
للشعب بقدر الامكان لان هذا هذه واحده من
ان لم تكن الافكار فهي واحده من افقر
الدول في العالم هذا ما نهدف اليه
وبالتالي فاننا ناسف ان نرى اثر تلك
القرارات على برامجنا وان لم تمكن من
تنفيذ هذه البرامج او
همم تحقيقها فانا سيكون هناك طبيعه ذلك
القدر من هذه الكلمه اللي ممثل الامم
المتحده في افغانستان طبعا العنوان
الرئيسي هو ارسال لجنه لكي تحاول ان تقنع
طالبا بالعدول عن قراراتها فيما يتعلق
بمنع المراه ان كان من الذهاب الى المدرسه
او العمل في المنظمات الحكوميه على كل
نعود الان الى ملف التاسع والمتعلق بتاديه
همم الحكومه الجديده برئاسه اهو اليمين
همم الدستوريه رغم كل الانتقادات التي
وجهت لها في ظل ما عرف بانها ضغط عليها
صفه ااه اليمين همم او اقصى اليمين على
كلن معي الان عبر زوم من تل ابيب الون
ايفتار مستشار سابق في وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه وابدا بالتصريحات الاخيره
التي صدرت عن الرئيس الامريكي والذي قال
فيها بحسب العواجل بانه يتطلع للتعاطي
والتعامل مع الحكومه الجديد كلمه السر
التي خرجت لانه كان في انتقادات امريكيه
لتشكيله هذه الحكومه في السابق
اكيد اكيد تنقد وتناقدات مش بس من من
امريكا في كمان من داخل اسرائيل
معسكر المركز واليسار على سياسه
المتوقع تبع الحكومه الجديده والتشكيل
وهيكل الحكومه الجديده هي تعتمد
دينيه ومن اليمين الاسرائيلي ولا لسه
بشكل مفعوله اه
على كل حال اييي اديني كمان البيت الابيض
بالشكل المناسب يعني بتنسيق
وبتعاون من اجل المهمات الكبيره والجوهريه
واول
رئيس يربط الولايات المتحده مع اسرائيل ام
انه ايضا الملف الفلسطيني وحل الدولتين من
ضمنها لانه همم
نتحدث عن هذه النقطه واكد التزام الولايات
المتحده بحل الدولتين هل يتصدق هذا مع
توجهات الحكومه
صحيح في موضوعين جوهريه على طاوله اول شيء
ومن
الاسرائيليه كمان الموضوع الايراني
الجديده
الفلسطينيه بدون اي مشاكل جوهريه او بدون
تغيير
تكرار في همم في المجال
الفلسطينيين من اجل وصول الى تنسيق كامل
مع امريكان في المانيا
ولم يفعل شيء بعض الانجازات بعد الاوراق
التي تحدث عنها حتى فيما يتعلق باختراق
للمفاعل والمعلومات التي تم تسريبها
استهدافات هنا وهناك عملاء علماء عذرا
ولكن بالنهايه لم يكن هناك من تحرك قوي
اذا ما صح التعبير ما الذي يمكن ان يفعله
الان
بصراحه لحد هلا ما في انجاز سياسي
وامني قوي وجدي بموضوع الصحه
كمان نحنا بنعرف انه اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
بهذه الموضوع
صلاحيه روسيه كمان في السنه الاخيره نحن
شايفين انه
رغم كمان الاحتجاج اجتماعي والاقتصادي
داخل ايران ما في اي تقدم بالعكس
موضوع العالم ضد ايران وكمان
الهدف المركزي وهذا راح يكون فرضا وسريعه
من تل ابيب مستشار سابق في وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه
ردود الفعل على الحكومه في هذا وفي ردود
الفعل عذرا قدمت سفيرته اسرائيل في فرنسا
يائيل جيرمان استقالتها بعد نيل حكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو الثقه من الكنيسه ونشرت
على تويتر في منتصف النهار رساله بالعبريه
ارسلتها الى رئيس الحكومه الجديد قالت
السفيره في الرساله ان سياسه وتصريحات
وزراء الحكومه
ونواياها التشريعيه تتعارض مع ما وصفته
بمبادئ اسرائيل
في التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
قيود طالبان تهدد باستمراريه الجامعات
الافغانيه ومجموعه السبع تدعو الحركه الى
التراجع عن قراراتها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا نكمل التاسعه من اوكرانيا
حيث استيقظ سكان عده مدن على السلسله
ضربات روسيه جديده ضربات استهدفت البنى
التحتيه ومرافق الطاقه في عز الشتاء
الخالق في مدينه البيت ادت الضربات الى
حرمانه 90% من اهل المدينه من الكهرباء
بعد ان اعلن تموسكو ليلا عن الحد الادنى
للتفاوض بشان الحرب في اوكرانيا وهو
الاعتراف بضم المناطق الاربعه ها هي موسكو
تغذيه صباحا على اصوات انفجارات طالت
العاصمه ومعظمه مدن البلاد بصوارخ كاليبر
واس 300 اطلقت من البحر الاسود وبحر ازوف
وشبه جزيره القرم بلغ عددها 64 صاروخا دمر
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني منها 54 صاروخا
بالنسبه بلغ الثمانيه
بالمئه وهي نسبه اعتبرها القائد العام
للقوات المسلحه الاخرانيه الجنرال فاليري
زولوجي نسبه جيده جدا من نظري الى حجم
البلاد
الابواب خلعت الان نفكر فيما يمكننا ان
نفعله المنزل بارد جدا ويجب ان نجد حلا
بسرعه الى القبو حدث انفجارين لقد كان ذلك
امورعبا كنت خائفا على الاطفال كان نصيب
العاصمه من القصف الروسي صباح اليوم 16
صاروخا اسقطتها جميعا انظمه دفاع المدينه
مخالفه دمار كبيرا حيث اقف الان جميع
المباني المحيطه دمرت بشكل كامل او جزئي
كما اصيب ثلاثه اشخاص ونقلوا لتلقي
الرعايه الصحيه ويواصل عمال الانقاذ يرفع
الانقاذ والبحث عن الضحيه يعني
المستشفى لاجراء عمليه وهناك طفله في
الرابعه عشر من عمرها اصيبت ايضا وجميع
المنازل تضررت
الاستهداف الروسي وكان واسعا نطاق فطال
مدينه ميكا لايف واوديسا في الجنوب
وخاركيف وسومي وبلطافا في الشرق في الشمال
وحتى اقصى الغرب الاوكراني مدينه الفيف لم
تسلم فتسعون بالمائه من المدينه دون
كهرباء او ميه 140 بالمئه من كيف على ذات
الحال ومعظم مدن اوكرانيا تعاني من فقدان
هذه الخدمات الاساسيه نتيجه هذا القصف
حذيفه العربيه كيف
وكان المفوض العسكري لمنطقه برست في
بيلاروسيا اولنج كونفالوف قال انه تم
اكتشافه شظايا لصاروخ اوكراني في حق زراعي
صباح اليوم في المنطقه اوكرانيا تقول بانه
روسيا
صباحا في منطقه ايفانفسكي اكتشفنا شظايا
لصاروخ للقوات الاوكرانيه من نوع اس 300
وذلك يشبه الى حد كبير ما حدث مؤخرا مع
سقوط صاروخ مماثل على الاراضي البولنديه
فاشله حتى اللحظه بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
ثلاثه منها في بيلاروسيا واحده افتراضيه
والاخيره في اسطنبول التركيه جميعها لم
تنجح في التوصل الى نقاط مشتركه طبعا بشان
المسائل الخلافيه ووضع نهايه للحرب الشروط
على تناقضها غير قابله للنقاش بحسب
الطرفين لكن رغما انسداد افقوق المفاوض
واستبعاد تسجيل ايخرق يتمسك الرئيس سان
بوتين وزنسكي بضروره التفاوض وانهاء الحرب
بطريقه دبلوماسيه وفق تعبيرهم سنبدا
بالشروط التي وضعها اوكرانيا اولها توحيد
الاراضي الاخرانيه نتحدث هنا طبعا عن عوده
المناطق الاربعه شرقي البلاد الى جنب شبه
جزيره القرم التي ضمتها موسكو عام 2014
ثاني هيتمثل بسحب القوات الروسيه ووقف
العمليات القتاليه واعاده الحدود بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا لسابق عهدها من ضمن
المطالب محاسبته مرتكبي اجرائم الحرب من
روسيا والافراج عن كل السجناء وطبعا ضمان
امن الطاقه وايضا الغذاء موقف كيف وفق
صحيفه تايمز باتاثر تشددا مع تضاعف
الاتهامات للجنود الروس بارتكاب جرائم حرب
واستمرار نجاح القوات الاوكرانيه في ميدان
المعركه الصحيفه غير ان شروطها لم تلقى
اصداء ايجابيه لدى روسيا
امتلئت شعبتها هي الاخرى بمطالب لم
تستسغها كيف واليكم تلك المطالب الروسيه
[موسيقى]
المزيد ينضم الينا عبر سكايب مناكير وهو
مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني اهلا بك سيد
يور يسمح لي ان ابدا بهذه الشروط
الاوكرانيه القويه الان انسحابات وغيرها
من كامل المناطق التي تسيطر عليها روسيا
على ماذا تعول اكياف هل فعلا النجاحات على
الارض يمكن ان تعتبر ورقه قويه الان في
يدها لفرض شروطها
تاكيد
القوات المسلحه
الجيش الروسي على هزيمه تلو الاخرى
صواريخ وكما شاهدنا اليوم كان هناك ضرب
مكثفه روسيه صاروخيه همم
54 منها وبالتالي همم
على محطات توليد الطاقه الكهربائيه في
كثير من الممر
شروطنا ما زالت كما هي ولم تتغير
المفاوضات
همم
ستبدا بعد الانسحاب الكامل للقوات الروسيه
ولا نرى اي استعداد او رغبه حقيقيه من
الروس لتحقيق هذه الشروط وضربات صاروخيه
اليوم هي دليل الاخر على ان روسيا لا تنوي
التفاوض بل تواصل الارهاب وجرائد
ليست فقط ما بين روسيا وكياف الان لانه
همم سيد يوري هناك صاروخ سقط بغض النظر عن
الجهه ان كانت روسيا التي اسقطته كما تقول
كليب او كانت اوكرانيا اسقطته كما تتهمها
بيلاروسيا الا ان ذلك يشير بصوره او باخرى
ان ربما جغرافيه الحرب تتسع هل تتخوفون من
ذلك
ان روسيا في الواقع لا تنوي التوقف في
اوكرانيا وفي الوقت الراهن في مركز هذه
الحرب هو همم في الشرق وفي الجنوب ولكن
خطه القوات الروسيه هي السيطره على
اوكرانيا وهذا امر لن يستطيع فعله
لكنهم انت ما كانوا
بدونها همم غربا
المنطقه الرئيسيه للمعارك هي شرقي
اوكرانيا والقوه الاوكرانيه المسلحه همم
اسابيع الاخيره القوات الاوكرانيه
التي كانت تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
وبالتالي انه نتوقع ان يستمر هذا الامر
سات مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اكثر من 26 رياضيا وفنانا وطبيبا يواجهون
خطرا لاعدام في ايران بعضهم قضى محاكمات
سوريا دون اتاحه اي تمثيل قانوني من بين
هؤلاء لاعب كره القدم السابق امير نصر
ازاداني والذي اعتقل في اصفهان في الثامن
عشر من نوفمبر الماضي حكم عليه بالاعدام
بتهمه الخيانه والتمرد المسلحه على الدوله
رياضيون اخرون مصيرهم مشابه ينتظرون حكما
بالاعدام او انه صدر بالفعل ولم يخرج
للعلم الرياض محمد مهدي كرامه حكم عليه
بالاعدام بعد ادانته بالفساد في الارض
والاعتداء على احد عناصر المسيج خلال
الاحتجاجات في كراج المصارع سهيل جيهان
جيري اعتقل في السادسه عشر من نوفمبر شهر
نوفمبر شهد ايضا اعتقال صالح ميرشمي وهو
مدرب بطل المنتخب الكاراتيه ولا يزال قيد
استجواب القوات الامنيه الايرانيه اعتقلت
ايضا
بار هو متسلق صخور في شيراز جنوبيه البلاد
وقبل ذلك اعدمت المصارع مجيد رضا
رهنرد بعد 23 يوما على اعتقاله
[موسيقى]
كبرى في افغانستان بانها ستواجه واحده من
اسوا ازمات الجوع في التاريخ
مشدده على ان دور الموظفات الافغانيات مهم
لاصال المساعدات الانسانيه في جميع انحاء
افغانستان
هذا واغلق جماعه امورا النسائيه في كابول
ابوابها بالكامل بعد قرار طالبان منع
تعليم الفتيات تعتبر هذه الجامعه اول
جامعه نسائيه بالكامل من الموظفات والطلبه
والاساتذه وتندرج تحت مؤسسه مورا للتعليم
والتي تضم مدارس وجامعه ومراكز تدريب
واسكان للطالبات فيما تم افتتاحها عام
2016 وتضم ما يقارب
550 طالبه وذلك في مختلف التخصصات
[موسيقى]
كان وزراء خارجيه الدول مجموعه السبع قد
دعوا حركه طالبان الى الالغاء العاجل
لقرار حظر عمل النساء في المنظمات غير
الحكوميه في افغانستان ووفقا لبيان
المشترك نشرته وزاره الخارجيه البريطانيه
اعربت الدول عن قلقها من القرار الذي يعرض
حياته ملايين الافغان للخطر بسبب اعتمادهم
على المساعدات الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
في كوسوفي وعقب التصعيد الذي استمر لايام
في منطقه البلقان وصل حد اعلان صربيا عن
تاهب جيشها على الحدود مع كوزوفو اعلن
الرئيس الصربي عن تفكيك الحواجز التي
اقامها صرب كوسوفو في شمال البلاد نتابع
شمال
البلاد قد تفكك معها ازمه خطيره تكاد تعصف
المنطقه
جنوب شرقي اوروبا تحرك الجيش الصربي وتاهب
على الحدود قرب كسفه ردت كوسوفو باغلاق
اكبر معبر حدود
تاتي التطورات على خلفيه احتجاجات للصرد
في مدينه مترو فيتشا الشمالي كوسوفو قطع
المحتجون الطرق منذ ثلاثه اسابيع
تصيد صربيا لم يخلوا من رسائل تهديد واضحه
وربما ابعد فالغرب القلق يدرك جيدا معنى
اشعال حرب جديده في المنطقه كما يدرك ان
ثمه توريطا اخر يلوح في الافق تبدو روسيا
حاضره وبقوه الرئيس الصربيه حليف لروسيا
والاخيره لم تتاخر في اعلان دعمها لصربيا
في الازمه الراهنه وهو ما يشير ربما بدور
روسي في تطورات الاخيره وفق تقريرا لمعهد
كارنيجي
التقرير ذهب ايضا الى ان روسيا تسعى الى
فتح جبهه جديده ضد الغرب في الخاصره
الاوروبيه الضعيفه بمنطقه البلقان
الموقف الغربي المطالب بالامتناع عن
الاستفزاز وتهديدات واعمال الترتيب دعا
الى نزع فتيل التوتر وضبط النفس من دون
شروط
تهدئه ربما غير ان الاوضاع هناك تبقى
مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات في بؤره تغذيها
ازمات معقده تاريخيا قد تنفجر في اي لحظه
القتل تتجاوز 60 شخصا معظمهم في بطنه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى التاسعه مشروع قانون
جديد حول الاحوال الشخصيه اثار جدلا وقلقا
لدى المصريين تحديدا ولديهم نيه للزواج
قريبا ففي اطار ما وصفه الرئيس المصري
بالحرص على كيان الاسره ودعمها يشمل مشروع
القانون صندوقا خاصا يمونه المقبلون على
الزواج حديثا مواد عده معلنه من مشروع
القانون المثير للجدل توقف عندها المصريون
كالتوثيق الطلاق الذي رفضه الازهر سابقا
اي عدم الاعتراف بالطلاق
الشفهانيها وجوب اخذ الماذون لموافقه قبل
اتمام عقد الزواج والقاضي سيقرر بعض اطلع
على فحوصات طبيه للزوجين للنظر في سلامه
المقبلين على الزواج واهليتهم بدنيا وايضا
نفسيا لكن وديعه الزواج ان صحت تعبير كانت
الاشد واقعا لدى الشباب المصري لما تشكله
من عباء مالي اضافي على الراغبين بالزواج
يضاف الى مصاريف عقد قرار من المتوقع
للانتهاء من مشروع القانون قانون الاحوال
الشخصيه الجديد بالكامل خلال الشهر قبل ان
يتم تقديمه للبرلمان المصري
تحاول احلام عدلي منذ اربع سنوات الحصول
على الطلاق ولا يكفي راتبها الذي يقل عن
100$ في الانفاق على اطفالها الثلاثه
بينما يتهرب الزوج من الانفاق على اطفاله
او الطلاق
زي دوت اللي الريس ينزل الدعم دوت اكيد
هيساعد معي في الثلاث عيال اللي انا
شايلاهم لوحدي
والدروس كلها
[موسيقى]
قضايا الطلاق الذي تصل نسبته الى
36% يتم الان وضعه قانون جديد للاحوال
الشخصيه اتضحت بعد موده ومن بينها
للمقبلين على الزواج ضروره اجراء كشف طبي
شامل واجراء تحليل للمخدرات الى جانب منح
صلاحيات جديده للقاضي وتحديد الذمه
الماليه للزوجين وانشاء صندوق لرعايه
الاسره ووثيقه تامين لدعمها في مواجهه
النفقات والتحديات ذات الصله وخاصه في حال
حدوث الطلاق
هذا الصندوق بيتكفل بدعم الاسره في
اوقاتها الحرجه زي لسيادتك تفضلت بها كده
طب الدعم بتاعه هيجي منين سيادتك تفضلت ان
الحكومه هتساهم في هذا الصندوق بقدر ما
يساهم فيه
المتزوجين اه برغم عدم تحديد المبالغ التي
سيددفعها المقبل على الزواج في الصندوق
الجديد حتى الان الا ان جدلا كبيرا اثير
على صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي وسط الخشيه
من ارتفاع المبالغ المطلوبه وهو ما قد
يؤدي الى الالتفاف حول الشروط الموضوعتي
في القانون الجديد
هو على حسب المبلغ بصراحه يعني انا ما
اعرفش ان المبلغ كم في ناس بتقول 30,000
وفي ناس بتقول 20 وانا مش عارف الحقيقه
فين بصراحه لكن لو هو المبلغ ده هو المبلغ
كبير جدا طبعا انا مع صندوق دعم الاسره
قلبا وقالبا لان المراه حقها مهدور وبيقف
دورها عند ان هي تاخذ حكم المحكمه وحليني
بقى عشان ننفذ واقي القبض على احد
العاملين في مكتب ماذون حتى المواطنين
بالاصرار في عقد قرانهم قبل اقرار القانون
لتلافي دفع مبالغ وصفها بالراهبه ما فيش
اي جهه من الجهات الرسميه في الدوله تكلمت
ان هو المقبل على زواج هيسدد للصندوق
30,000 جنيه هذا الشخص بمجرد الفحص تبين
ان هو مش ماذون اصلا قانون الاحوال
الشخصيه الجديده اثار جدلا قبل اقراره
جدله متوقع قد يدفع القائمين عليه لتعديل
بعد موده قبل طرحه على الحكومه والبرلمان
راند ابو العزم العربيه القاهره
ومن القاهره ينضم الينا وليد عبد المقصود
وهو رئيس مبادره معا لانقاذ الاسره
المصريه اهلا بك استاذ وليد اسمحلي ان
ابدا بقراءه بهذا القانون هل هو بديل عن
القانون السابق تعديل على القانون السابق
والهدف الاساسي هو تاهيل الاجيال مستقبلا
يعني فوائده على المدى البعيد ام لا نحن
نتحدث عن ربما ايجاد حلول الاسر
اهلا وسهلا بحضرتك
وبالساده المشاهدين عايز اقول في البدايه
ان انا باعتبر اني مشروع انشاء قانون
بصندوق رعايه الاسره هو واحد من اهم
الانجازات في ال 50 سنه الاخيره في اطار
الحمايه المجتمعيه للاسره المصريه لا يخفى
على احد ان الاسره المصريه تعاني انقسام
ما بعده انقسام والنسبه ال 36% بتاعه
الطلاق دي غير صحيحه النسبه همم تصل الى
44% حضرتك للاسف الشديد في احكام بالنفقه
بتكون قيمتها قليله جدا لا تكفي ثمن اي
شيء وبنك ناصر الاجتماعي بيقوم بسداد مبلغ
500 جنيه في 500 جنيه في ظل الاسعار اللي
موجوده بمبلغ طبعا همم يعني ما ينفعش طبعا
من ثمان سنين اشتغلنا على ملف تعديل قانون
الاحوال الشخصيه وكنا بنطالب ان يكون في
صندوق له الاسره المصريه طب الصندوق ده
هيبقى دوره ايه هو توصيل حكم النفقه للحد
الادنى للحياه الكريمه يعني ايه الحكم
مثلا ب 500
اولا كل الارقام اللي بتتقال على السوشيال
ميديا مغلوطه ما فيش رقم ولا تصريح برقم
ولسه ده مشروع بيتم اعداده نمره 2 احنا
كنا قلنا ايه في الموضوع دوت كنا قلنا ان
احنا عايزين نبقى في طبع اسره احد بيبني
شركه حد بيبني مصنع حد بيبني صحيفه بيبني
قناه فضائيه بيعمل اي مشروع هيبقى فيه طبع
اسره قضايا الاسره وقضايا في المحاكم
هيبقى عليها رسم للاسره ان ندعم بها
الصندوق
كراسات التحاق بالكليات الحربيه والشرطه
كراسات الشروط بتاعه وزاره الاسكان همم
مبلغ زهيد من رسوم الانديه همم التذاكر
الطيران كل ده ندمجه في صندوق الاسره ليه
اي احد بيتكلم مش عارف حجم المشكله احنا
عندنا اطفال مش بتلاقي تاكل واطفال متشرده
واطفال للاسف الشديد في حاله يرثه لها لما
الدوله تتخطى وتحاول ان هي تتخطى هذه
الكارثه وهذا الوضع الخطير لازم طبعا كلنا
مهاجم اللي بيهاجم اما بيهاجم طول الوقت
لان هو مش مش عايز اي حاجه تتم او بيهاجم
اي قرار للحكومه واحنا واحنا
تسمح لي يعني بعيدا عن المشاكل همم
الاسريه بصوره خاصه نحن نتحدث عن وضع
اقتصادي قاسي جدا ليس فقط على المصريين
ولكن بصوره عامه ولا بالتالي عندما تاتي
للمواطل
لتقول له ان يضيف على
ضغوطات عليه لكي يتزوج ربما لن يتزوج ابدا
بصي يا فندم انا انا عارف كويس ان احنا في
وضع اقتصادي صعب وشديد الصعوبه مش على
مستوى مصر على مستوى العالم وده يمكن هو
السبب الاكبر ان لازم الصندوق يتعمل
دلوقتي على فكره لان الوضع الاقتصادي ده
هو الوضع الاقتصادي على الشباب المقبل على
الزواج بس يعني الاطفال اللي في حاله يرثى
لها ما لهمش وضع اقتصادي لما يكون فيه
احكام نفع لغايه النهارده ب 500 و600 جنيه
الاطفال دي هتعيش من فين احنا كده بنسمح
لهم ان هم يتشرده او يتسربوا من التعليم
او يشتغلوا في سن مبكر بما هو ضد اللي
اعرفه ضد الانسانيه او ان هم يروحوا بقى
يلجاوا للجريمه النهارده احنا بنحافظ
عليهم احنا عايزين مبلغ صغير بالمناسبه
يعني مش عايزين ان يكون في مبلغ كبير على
عاطف الشباب الدوله
من نقاط اخرى موجوده في نقطه ايضا لفتاه
في ما يتعلق
باهليه الذي يريد او المقبل على امواج
صحيه ممكن نفهمها نفسيا كيف هاي باختصار
لو سمحت
عايزين نقفل بس النقطه بتاعه صندوق الاسره
والنقطه اخيره نقول احنا اللي للاسف
الشديد ممكن نعمل اي مظاهر للفرح اي مظاهر
للطرف للفشخره سوري يعني في الشارع في
الحاره في اي مكان شعبي كلنا بنعمل افراح
بتتكلم لكن ما عندناش للاسف الشديد ان
احنا نحط مبلغ ولو بسيط في صندوق للاسره
بالمناسبه الكلام ده كل الشركه والاقامه
العاملين لما لما الموظف بيخرج على المعاش
بياخذ من صندوق دوت ويعيش وقت يعني كنت
سالتك سؤال ولكن لم يعد لدينا الوقت
لا يخفى على احد ان الجرائم الاسريه اللي
شهدتها مصر في الاونه الاخيره جرائم غير
مسبوقه ولذلك كان الكشف النفسي للمقبلين
على الزواج هو شيء مهم جدا احنا عايزين
الاثنين اللي جايين يتزوجوا دول اللي
هيخدموا هيبنوا اسره نعرف ونتاكد من سلامه
الصحه النفسيه لهم لان للاسف سنين اللي
احنا شوفنا طبعا احنا تعذيب غير مسبوقه من
القاهره وليد عبد المقصود رئيس مبادره معا
لانقاذ الاسره المصريه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
تجددت الاشتباكات الداميه في اقليم دارفور
في السودان مثيره عن مقتل تسعه اشخاص
لترتفع على الحصيله الاجماليه الى 20
قتيلا بعد اشتباكات السبت الماضي افاد
المتحدث باسم التنسيقيه العامه للاجئين
والنازحين في داركور ادمرجال ان افراد من
قبيله رزيقات على الدراجات الناريه
ومسلحون الشبكه مع افراد من قبيله البور
يقتلون في مخيم لبنازحين
[موسيقى]
رئيس الحكومه الليبيه
رئيس مجلس النواب مشروع قانون الموازنه
العامه لعام 20 23 لعرضها على المجلس ونقل
التلفزيون المسار الليبي عن خطاب وجهها
الى رئيس مجلس النواب عقيله صالح وقد قال
فيه قال همم ان قيمه مشروع الموازنه
تتجاوز 57.5 مليار دينار اي حوالي 12
مليار دولار امريكي
[موسيقى]
الخساره الكبيره افضل من الافلاس هكذا
يتعامل للمستثمرون بالعملات الرقميه مع
الانهيارات والاضرار التي لمت بهذا السوق
اي سرعه التصرف اولا تفاديا لاضرار وخساره
اكبر في استثماراتهم بحسب صحيفه
بعد انهيار شركات تداول العملات الرقميه
مثل
نتورك من العملاء لبيع اصولهم بخصومات
كبيره لا يضروا الى الانتظار اشهر او ربما
سنوات لمعرفه ما قد يستردونه منها
فاجراءات الافلاس قد لا تضمن لهم بالضروره
نتيجه افضل من عائدات مبيعاتهم الان كما
انها تستغرق وقتا اطول مما يمكن ان يتحمله
عدد من المستثمرين بعضهم يحتاج الاموال
الان عرضت العملات البيعه عبر الانترنت من
خلال مواقع تديرها شركات متخصصه بطلبات
الافلاس وايضا تمويل المستحقات من بينها
اصول بقيمته
26 مليون دولار تقريبا في اكس سليم منها
اكثر من 91 مليون دولار خاصه بعملاء اف تي
اكس بحسب وول ستريت جولنال كان قطاع
التشفير شهيدا عاما قاسيا واخر الضربات
طلاقتها همم كور سينترفك التي اعلنت
افلاسها
[موسيقى]
تبعت حصيله الضحايا العاصفه الثلجيه التي
تشهدها ولايه نيويورك الامريكيه لتبلغ
واحدا و60 قتيلا فيما رشحت فرق الطوارئ
الرقم للارتفاع مجددا مع انحصار الثلوج في
غضون ذلك اكد عمده بافلو ان المدينه
الواقعه على الحدود الكنديه احصت لوحدها
34 قتيلا فيما لا تزال اكثر من 1000 عائله
من ديون كهرباء
[موسيقى]
وهذه وقفه مع ابرز احداث اكتوبر لهذا
العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وان كنت نيوز
هي من توفتناك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الى العناوين
سوريا
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها لجيش النظ
ام السعودي
روسيا ترد على شروط اوكرانيا للتفاوض بقصف
بعشرات الصواريخ خلال العاصمه والبيض
[موسيقى]
في مصر مشروع قانون الاحوال الشخصيه يثير
الجدل قبل تقديمه الى البرلمان
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت ولكن المزيد الان
مع طاهر و30
ضيعت بالارقام
ههه شكرا للاسف نحن مع خبر وفاه اسطوره
كره القدم البرازيليه بيليه بعد معاناه
طويله مع المرض شكرا لك
[موسيقى]